[Music]
it is an issue which cuts to the core of
what america means what it stands for
my choice
my choice and both sides in this most
polarizing of debates have been
electrified by the supreme court leak
the suggestion that it could be about to
remove the constitutional right to
abortion
the march in the capital was one of
hundreds across the nation for those who
believe abortion is a fundamental right
this was their day to be heard we need
to get out here and fight for our rights
it's completely unfair to let some a
bunch of old men
and people who are completely out of
touch with the rest of america choose
our fate we're the land of the free you
shouldn't be driving across state lines
to try to get something that's so
integral and that so many people have
figured out and yet we're free but we
have not figured it out
thank you it's your choice
it isn't just something that's
profoundly personal for so many people
it is an issue which touches on so many
aspects of life here in the united
states
[Music]
and under the shadow of the washington
monument the politics they are unelected
they are unaccountable and they are
unrepresentative
[Applause]
the religion race and equality but at
its most basic they say this is about
health care
watching and listening adam and his
parents
women really should have the ultimate
decision it's not our right to lay laws
about what they can do and what they
can't do with their bodies
it's a very emotional issue for me and i
could go on and on and on but it is just
unbelievable that in my lifetime and i
feel like it's just the start and that's
even scarier
[Music]
part of their purpose here is to hint at
what they see are the consequences of
banning abortion a healthcare crisis
that would hit the poorest hardest and a
step back in time
[Music]
we don't yet know exactly when the
decision by the judges will come only
that it will be by july mark stone sky
news in washington
two-thirds of people